the problem with the covet vaccine i'll
tell you
well here's the problem is they
they have all these vaccines and they
recognize that it's going to be really
hard to get a vaccine that does what
people
say they think it's going to do so they
have been reducing the standards
to make it so that they can pass a
vaccine no matter what
and what they think it's going to do is
make it so that they don't have to worry
about covet at all
right right is that what they're if you
get a shot you're protected you're good
and and that you're not going to
transmit it okay
and that and particularly we want to
make sure that the
people who are vulnerable so people with
comorbidities
and fragile elderly that it's going to
keep them from dying
um but what they did is the the testing
protocols that they're using do not
require them to show any of those things
the testing process and i'll tell you
how it works
they take 22 000 people and they give
them the pfizer vaccine
and they took 22 000 people and give
them a placebo
and then they wait and it's double blind
so
it's supposed to work is neither the
patients
the subjects test subject volunteers or
the
um researchers know who got what okay
and then you wait till 100 people get
sick from covid
that takes a while because you know you
have 40 000 people and
it's it's kind of hard nowadays
to get sick from coving you're not going
to have you know you're not going to
have the majority of those people
exposed so
after 100 people get sick they
stop the study and look at it and then
they say
how many of those people got the vaccine
and how many got the placebo okay
and if 50 percent of the vaccine of 50
percent of the
placebo means there's zero efficacy in
the vaccine doesn't work well in this
case with pfizer everybody's excited
because 90 they
they stopped the study when 95 people
got sick
and apparently 85 of those people
were in the placebo group
which means the vaccine appears to be 90
effective here's the problem they
the way they measure whether you have
covid
is that you have one positive pcr test
you have one positive pcr test and you
have one symptom so that could be a
cough
it could be a fever it could be a chill
it could be a headache
and you have covet so what they're
testing the vaccine for
is not what we want to know does it
prevent you from dying
right does it prevent you from being
hospitalized understood
and you and we don't we will never know
from
because they have they have geared back
the studies
of it is to make them as peter toshi who
is the editor of the british medical
journal
he said this in new york times editorial
he said these studies were designed to
succeed so that you cannot fail
no matter how bad the vaccine is it's
going to pass
because we want a vaccine right
everybody wants vaccines so we can
restart the economy
the big problem with this vaccine
there's two problems
one is it does not prevent transmission
that means i can get the vaccine
and then i get exposed to kovid i still
give covert to you and everybody on the
airplane
you just don't experience it i don't
experience it but it makes it even more
dangerous
because normally you don't even know you
have it if i
i'd stay home and i wouldn't infect
buddy but if i'm feeling like a million
bucks
and i'm still i become a super spreader
like you know typhoid mary
oh yeah you don't want that and yet
that's what
apparently this vaccine does it stops
you from knowing it but you continue to
transmit it the
other problem is that they're only
testing them for a month or two months
you're not going to see bad side effects
until maybe a year out a lot of these
um you know injuries that you get from
vaccines have very long
incubation periods autoimmune disease
like diabetes rheumatoid arthritis
graves disease crohn's disease
um ibs you won't see these
or food allergies yeah it takes a long
time for those to incubate inside of the
body
and what fizer's doing which is very
dishonest
is as soon as it finishes the study
it unblinds it so that everybody knows
you got the magazine you got the placebo
and then it takes all the people in the
placebo group
and it gives them the real vaccine so
now
we completely are unable to tell whether
there's a long term and it's like
covering your future tracks kind of yeah
exactly and it's a trick that they've
used in the vaccine injury
i industry that's the same thing they
did with the gardasil vaccine
but it makes it impossible for anybody
to ever know whether the reason they're
getting sick was because of that vaccine
or weather which
is bad luck so why is it that we've
become so
like why is it our government that's
giving so much power to these um
to these companies and less less
thoughtfulness to the safety of humanity
like
who's who i mean the problem is the
entire
sort of medical cartel is now
feeding at the tit of big pharma yes oh
the the universities are getting all
their money from
from you know from sponsoring clinical
trials
um the the regulatory agencies have
become
are are what you know are subject to
what we call regulatory capture
they've become sock puppets for the
industry that they're supposed to
regulate
and you know you see that everywhere i
mean i've been suing regulatory agencies
for 40 years epa
and you know and um and the state agency
that for example
famously in louisiana is utterly run by
the oil industry is corrupt
but um the corruption is particularly
acute
in hhs and the reason for that
is that that the agencies are really
part of the industry
so half of cdc's budget goes to buying
and selling vaccines
fda or or fda half of its budget comes
from the pharmaceutical companies
and with nih which is the other big
agency
they are collecting tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of dollars
on vaccine patents so they work on the
vaccine at the outset
they transferred the patent to gilead or
pfizer
the modern vaccine was completely
developed by tony fauci
he hands it to a private group they then
they put two billion dollars of federal
money into
allowing them to develop it and then
tony fauci's agency keeps half the
profits from the vaccine
oh it would be like you know i've sued
epa
many times for being a captured agency
but you know what would what would it be
like if the epa made half of its profits
selling coal yeah it's the same thing
these agencies are not
independent agencies they're completely
captured and
you have and you know the all of the
other
institutions of government that that
should stand between a greedy
corporation and a vulnerable child
have been compromised congressman
congress gets more money
lobbing money from the from the
pharmaceutical industry than any other
industry they give them
double what oil and gas because i'm
talking about lobbyists
there's more pharma lobbyists on capitol
hill than there are congressmen senators
and supreme court justices combined
regulatory agencies have been captured
the press
is utterly captured and that's because
in 1997 we passed a law in this country
or fda
you know changed regulation to make it
legal for the first time
for on television and radio and
newspapers to advertise pharmaceutical
products
on the air direct to consumer farms when
was that what year was that
i was 97 so oh there's only two
countries in the world that allow that
everybody agrees a terrible thing to do
oh and it's half of our commercials now
as well well roger ailes who founded fox
told me that
that there are 22 commercials on his
average
evening news show and 17 of those are
pharmaceutical
oh yeah i'm just trying to get through
half a family guy next thing you know i
have hiv by the end of the day so you
know what i'm saying it's just like
the fear it's in a lot of it's fear too
and they give you pictures of like oh
here's a happy family but you might have
this
looming in the distance you know yeah
yeah you might have
said that he wanted to do one of those
ads
where you know they you know they list
all these horrible things
from the side effects and the people are
walking around
happy and laughing and playing football
he said he just wants to do one of those
ads where people are actually
acting out the side effects
man he's so good they don't have a good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah